my book i was testing it all the time
and when i remember i remember there was
one person who's playing in this
tournament right now who kept refuting
my analysis and that was gwen jones and
i was following his games and he would
just like demolish my ideas against the
carol and i was like not fair have they
go back to my so i literally had to
scrap like weeks of analysis and uh yeah
work harder but it made it a better book
thank you thank you going and the only
way to test your opening analysis is to
play it against the best in the world so
uh hans there would have been really
interesting to see how doodle would
would have reacted to that uh opening
instead we see one of the main lines of
the english uh here white gaining space
black skinny space as well white was
actually attacking the black knight but
black counter-attacked against the white
knight this time and we'll see these
pieces traded off their hands finally
appearing
with his fresh new haircut and okay a
trade of knights a trade of pawns
black's queen coming out early but the
black queen will
maybe be a bit of a target for white's
pieces over the next few turns white
bishop move there
not as common as occupying the center
with the pawn or bringing the white
knight out but still
relatively
standard stuff so far
and uh we talked about troubled pawns
double pawns white has double pawns on
the c file but actually they're quite
strong they control the middle of the
board they control some central squares
so these types of double pawns are
probably the best type you'll ever see
they're not great at the best of times
but uh for now it's okay and hans
looking confident
uh for sure he's studied this he's not
just studied the job of london of course
he's studied a whole bunch of openings
his openings lately the teenager only 18
years old that's super strong he's won a
few games already in this tournament out
of his openings and talking about
openings i have a question from charlie
hill and this is in reference to
the last game that we saw from jordan
and he says
how long do you think jordan but in this
case could also be hans neiman will have
been preparing the opening for and do
you think you know he has practiced it
online without or without showing people
he is preparing it
very good question um that's one thing i
always do at least if i'm about to start
playing a new opening that i'm not so
familiar with at least in practical
terms
i don't have too much experience then
i'll always play online a bit first
firstly to make sure i actually like the
positions because on a computer screen
if the computer says plus one it might
look great but if you sit there and you
don't know the plans then
you might not enjoy it so much so that's
one thing but also learning what the
most common replies are
from your opponent
in those opening stages so yeah i think
these guys they're very professional
hans might only be 18 jordan's only 21
22
but they're opening experts and that's
why jordan for example was invited to
magnus's camp because he checks
everything really deeply with computers
he plays lots of practice games in his
openings and that's why the results are
so effective in tournament play yeah
and i should of course mention young
christoph duda he's had quite a
nightmare day he's lost all his games
today he started off in shared second
place and now he is in eighth place
fighting for qualification
wow that is such a bad day for him yeah
and uh especially because
at least yesterday he was really
starting to gain momentum and we've seen
him be a bit inconsistent on the
champions chess tour uh last season
playing in the finals but maybe not
quite at his best
and uh this year okay
needing to recover because
uh he really is expected a world cup
winner to make it deeper into the
knockouts meanwhile just to catch up
with the position black is the first to
cast for the king but white has that
opportunity at some point over the next
few moves and i'm surprised evaluation
buyers so far on white side but it must
be to do with the fact that black queen
is vulnerable to some attacks over the
next couple of turns and maybe we can
jump in just to show what hans is
thinking about right now
i think he just needs to castle as
quickly as possible get that king to
safety and uh once black continues the
development for example okay this knight
not doing anything these queen side
pieces asleep uh if the knight moves out
onto a very natural square then white
can start thinking about for example
pushing a pawn forward with ideas of
bringing his bishop out and hitting this
black queen it's all about this black
queen black needs to spend a few moves
uh keeping her safe maybe even having to
spend a move now just to stop this
bishop jumping out it would be too
strong but hans okay going his own way
he's very creative
instead of castling he first flicks in
this queen move
hitting this pawn in conjunction with
the bishop this pawn moved but i
mentioned this was maybe a move black
wants to play anyway this pawn move
stopping white's bishop from using the
square later white's knight from using
that square and finally we do see the
white king
castle itself away to safety personally
i'm not a huge fan of this move i think
the queen could have maintained her
flexibility
and maybe more priorities uh
the priority should have been to open up
the center and black's trying to clamp
down on that idea by pushing his pawn
forward so it's all about the tension in
the center can white push his pawn to
the middle or is black got this square
too well guarded white would love to
open things up but maybe not possible
right now
all right well young christophe duda you
mentioned world cup winner he is ready
to play in the candidates tournament
this summer the winner will uh face
magnus carlsen in the next world
championship match but uh news today
sergey kanyakin has been banned from
chess for six months by fee day and we
have a new story on this on chess24.com
this of course um
brings a big question mark about what
will happen he is qualified for the
candidates tournament
will he be able to play i mean probably
not because it's inside six months so
who will take his place well that is the
question isn't it and i i think i saw
some stats that if ding played
26 games by the end of may
he will be able to play the candidates
oh okay um yes so i saw i read the story
that the regulation is that the the
highest rated player in may
will get that spot uh right now that is
dingle iran he is world number three
world number two for russia has already
qualified
so but but the ding hardly plays because
of kovid he's not able to travel from
china um and levonaronian he's playing
the world cup um
sorry the grand prix starting tomorrow
so he could
catch up uh with thing on the rating
lists yeah either way that article on
chess 24 is fascinating yeah and it
looks like carrick and won't appeal
either so yeah that place has opened up
and i know fans chess fans they would
love to see ironian or ding both of them
yeah amazing players in the candidates
so yeah it's going to be an interesting
summer and finding magnus carlsen's next
challenger yep definitely so go ahead to
chess24.com to read all about that story
um
and young christoph duda he is however
ready to play in the candidates now a
few moves in the game yeah new moves and
white's last move a decent one but it
does maybe highlight the fact that
white's queen has lost a bit of time the
white queen started on uh on the d1
square of course and she kind of moved
to c2 then moved again to e2 square it
could have gone there one move hans has
lost a bit of time
over the last few turns and that's why
the evaluation bar is bang in the middle
white's advantage of the first move has
been negated by the fact that hans lost
a tempo as we call it in chess and the
queen moving yet again the third time
she's moved now
she could have got here in two squares
maybe and two moves so okay meanwhile i
traded bishops black's bishop
just retreating there um the one thing
that white has to be careful of long
term is that the doubled pawns don't
become an issue
in the endgame they might be a weakness
they might be a target for the opponent
and also if it comes down to pure kings
and pawns no pieces on the board then
double pawns have no flexibility to much
forward that's why we talk about them as
being so bad that's why in the queen's
gambit
it gave the main character nightmares
apparently these double pawns but for
now there's enough pieces left
and
the one thing black has to be careful of
meantime is in the meantime it's not
allowing white's pieces to get too
active at the moment it's fine white's
pieces on the bottom row the rooks look
okay but the bishop not great and okay
talking of activity hans is going for it
he's he's full of confidence as we've
seen before and he's going on the attack
similar to how jordan did it in the last
game using this pawn as a battering ram
he wants to advance again next move
attacking the black queen opening up
lines but this time it's more risky
because the white king also sits on this
side of the board yeah i i do wonder
whether he felt like positionally he was
going
in the wrong direction actually because
there were a lot of things that
potentially could be a big problem in
the long term so therefore he's like
okay let's uh speed things up let's
accelerate the play and let's initiate
chaos because this is a tricky move to
actually deal with because you know like
you say you know another porn is perhaps
going to launch itself harry the h ball
move it two squares the white king can
step up maybe the two rooks can swing
across to the right side and uh well
dude i just relax reacts very
principally actually because they say
when your opponent starts working on the
wings you should
focus your energies in the center
and they might lose some momentum on the
wings if they are distracted in the
center and
from the center of the board you can
kind of go off on both sides so right
now hans just taking another move out to
just improve his bishop attacking one of
black's pawns on the c5 square that pawn
is undefended i'm just being surprised i
must admit on every single turn white
started this plan of maybe launching a
kingside attack and then just took a
time out to improve a piece so it's
slightly inconsistent
but then again black does have to deal
with a threat against his pawn on the c5
square he does guard it and notice how
the black queen does guard the knight on
the c6 square white's queen eyeing that
piece up but for now everything holding
together
uh for duda yeah and ivanka is now the
time to go on the attack
and uh continue pushing pawns
you mentioned it like when you have
long-term weaknesses like white does
these double pawns on the left side you
need to counter often with dynamic fast
play yeah
i definitely think now is the time
sorry i'm a little bit distracted
because i saw this amazing tweet just
now and it's really really bad news for
david and
i'm really really sorry david to be the
bearer of bad news
but the person who won the tinky winky
oh yeah sorry that was the moves and
i've just got the analysis brought up so
before we talk about tinky winky i was
just saying white should attack the
black queen and i think he would have a
great position hans though playing a bit
too slowly carry on ivanka tell me about
what i what my fate is your fate is it
is christopher gresley the owner of the
good night who has won the tinky twinkie
what's this stinky winky kinky costume
and uh he's saying so ask your brain how
do you want this served
i'm going to get my revenge
i think we should just be part of the uh
the good night exhibition right this is
the this is the costume that david wall
what do you think
wow that is and everyone can try it on
and take pictures yeah in the costume
you know be like that good david i'm
trying to save you okay
okay
we'll see and talking about christopher
actually also i know he's the guest in
the next episode coming out uh about um
in the
uh not late not good night but late
night podcast with david and oscar
uh and being the owner of a chess pub
he will see a lot of tinder dates is my
bet yeah and that's one of the topics
actually of our podcast
to be released soon but actually just
recently we did release an episode with
ivanka yeah and with simon williams so
yeah there's right now on chest 24
there's an article about those podcasts
go check it out on spotify uh it's a lot
of fun and christopher of course full of
great stories
i wish i could tell some now
it's too early in the day yeah so okay
meanwhile
as mentioned white's attack is brewing
white did indeed push a pawn forward
hitting the black queen but that pawn
was captured and now
white hans neiman has a big big decision
to make does he go and recapture this
pawn on the g5 square with the white
knight or with the white bishop the
white bishop attacks the queen but the
queen will just move it's a temporary
thing only a one move threat if the
white knight captures it is placed on a
very good attacking square a very strong
attacking square either way i think jan
christoph duda
facing this attack wants to trade the
queens he knows that white has the
long-term weakness of double pawns so if
black's queen if it's sidesteps to the
g6 square next it's going to eye up
white's queen in the center a queen
trade only favors black so it's very
much short-term white's chances versus
long-term blacks chances right now
and uh still in the balance okay
hans niemon he had such a great first
day um
some bad results after that but he's
still uh inside top eight it would be a
big deal for him to qualify for
knockouts right he is one of the lowest
rated players here and also one of the
youngest as well yeah i forget that he's
still a teenager
and
i was checking out his uh performance in
recent years and his star is really in
the ascendant you know maybe two two
years ago he was around about
international master rating and now look
at him yeah he's competing amongst the
world's elite so it would be an
incredible achievement actually for him
to
to qualify but i don't think it would be
an incredible achievement in his eyes i
think he's very confident he's very
confident so i think he'll be like well
yeah of course i'm i'm a great player
and that's such a great thing in chess
that you have to be confident in your
abilities
and uh well we see bishop takes born
attacking the queen and i do have to
reinforce david's point which i really
love you know when you have the
strategic trumps and duda has played it
try to swap off queens neutralize the
initiative and then in the end game you
can start to make use of your opponent's
structural weaknesses
yeah and now with the queens off it's
going to be quite one-sided traffic i
feel
white is still solid for now
everything's protected but long-term the
doubled pawns
have no flexibility they could be
targets for black pieces
black also has the advantage of just two
porn islands if you look on the right
side black's pawns are connected there
left side connected white has isolated
pawns on both sides of the board both
the h pawn and the a pawn isolated so
long term it's all about black it's just
about whether black's pieces can get
organized to actually attack those
weaknesses and
yes just while you were talking about
hans he was actually at the beginning of
the pandemic he was known as mostly for
being a streamer he was streaming day in
day out constantly he had a huge
following online but um he's kind of let
that take a back seat now and he's
focused on his playing and that's really
paid off
in this tournament in fourth place so
far but um yeah against someone like
duda
usually
he would be struggling i think it's all
about duda's confidence today after
losing three games yeah because normally
i think duda would win this position
eight times out of ten maybe just
because it's so stable so long term and
i think against someone as energetic as
hands white's position is uh just going
to be so hard to defend but it's all
about confidence and duda if he's
impatient the advantage could fizzle out
maybe so
and our
our
odds oracle or stats oracle tai
sent me a message saying that duda's
odds to qualify dropped from over 98
to
64.8 percent with those three losses you
can never feel safe in this format never
ever remember there is three points for
a win zero for a loss one point for a
draw
and uh i mean it shows how well duda did
earlier in the tournament yeah he lost
three in a row and he's still just
inside the top true
but yeah that's that's why we're
focusing on this game it's so critical
uh for the standings for the
qualification yeah and also we'll be
critical for how uh duda actually feels
about today's
chain of events because the the funny
thing about chess is you could lose the
first three games but if you win the
fourth
it doesn't quite matter you know you're
just like oh yes yeah you know i won a
game excellent ending
exactly and now you can go on to the
fourth day
and you'll be feeling great yeah if he
uh draws perhaps a a good position or
something then it will just feel like
this is just a terrible day of chess and
oh my goodness me what am i doing and
then he'll have to reset and work very
very hard to be in the right mindset for
day four
absolutely
it's all going to be decided tomorrow
the eight players that will qualify for
the quarterfinals and
not many are feeling safe liam leia i
think is feeling quite safe but wow look
at that in his game against dingley ran
the bar all the way over to ding's side
that couldn't be liam first loss in the
tournament and we did see a rook move
yeah rook move and it looks like the
black king has just castled the king and
next to each other but nope that rook
has just swung across and actually the
idea i think is to start launching the
black f pawn down the board maybe to
attack the white bishop first but even
to push it two squares and that black
rook is actually a bit controlled it
wants to find an open line at the moment
struggling to do so so uh duda just
staying flexible and meanwhile hans
evacuating his king from any potential
kind of openings of the position so that
the black rooks could face that king
often kings are good in the center in
end games once the queens have gone and
uh maybe the other secondary motif is
that white's rooks now are ready to just
swing across to the g file on the same
line as the black king and just defend
things there challenge rooks there
and uh okay there we see the stock fish
evaluation uh the computer moves
wow dude finds the best move i was going
to say the top three moves all very
natural it's not clear which one's best
but dude of course plays the best move
notice how they're just lining up their
rooks with the opponent's kings if in
doubt that's often a good strategy to
scare the opponent but also tactics work
in your favor if rooks are opposite your
opponent's kings and queens
so
hey i'm taking notes yeah neiman he's
going to get his king out of the way
it's just too uncomfortable oh he isn't
wow he doesn't surprising brave well he
does the same right yeah
aiming for that black king now what
would you be thinking in this position
kyra even if if you were white or black
what would you prefer maybe i mean the
bar now
definitely i would prefer to be black
here yeah but it's a i think this is a
very tricky game
um but
i i mean
neiman had he went too slow right yeah
yeah because he he had so many
opportunities on on
on the uh
on the g and the h uh
lines but then
and you said it also he he used a lot of
time to to try to improve a few small
things yeah and uh now he's uh
no definitely this is duda's game yeah
i agree and that's the thing you've got
to be consistent right and he pushed
upon and then he took three or four
moves just to improve his pieces and uh
he allowed black to just trade queens if
he'd been a bit faster that opportunity
might not have existed for duda and
actually if you notice what's happened
we've just seen a trade of pawns white's
king now firmly in the middle of the
board
but those isolated pawns on those
doubled pawns sorry on the c file for
white they're extremely vulnerable uh
duda has exchanged off the pawn next to
it so now those pawns are
very loose they lack defenders and
already i'm seeing dangers with the
white king if you look at all of the
white pawns actually white has two
isolated pawns on the right side and uh
three very weak pawns on the right side
on the left side sorry and uh okay
advancing this pawn now but
there's not going to be an attack
against the black king the black king is
going to be safe once queens have been
traded
and yeah as you mentioned i think it's
very one-sided i'm surprised the
evaluation bar is actually um only 1.5
because it feels like the type of
position that could just fall apart
if white is careless in just one move
and wow yeah it's already really really
dangerous times for neiman okay
yeah maybe regretting not playing the
jaba london system is speciality
switching openings and maybe just not
being familiar with the pace with the
plans
and
yeah duda meanwhile looking very focused
and the bar is um over to magnus
carlsen's side in his game against
gawain jones as we mentioned ding may be
about to win against liam
and the bar is over to jew and jun's
side and her game against eric hanson
may be her second win of today
as you said eurica it's starting a trend
yes and that's what we want to see yeah
we definitely i mean she's the
three-time women's world champion so
she's a very very strong player and she
definitely must not be underestimated
and i'm trying to figure out how black
is going to break through so this i mean
i i really love black's position but i'm
really thinking how
should black proceed should black try to
improve the pieces i mean i'm thinking
about moving the king out of the eye
line of the white rook or maybe try to
improve the dark squared bishop
yeah black star square bishop a bit
ineffective right now um this piece
not really hitting anything just thin
air on this diagonal but i think maybe
your your first suggestion ivanka is
slightly uncomfortable right this
tension we've mentioned it before rook's
opposite kings there could be ideas for
example if black is too slow of white's
bishop moving in and creating a pin here
uh hitting this pawn in front of the
king so yeah why not get it out the way
when in doubt just move your king to
safety that could involve just stepping
off the file here it could involve maybe
stepping forward but then you do risk
for example knight jumps if you go
if you're too brave with the black king
so that's what i would start with at
least just move this king to the side
and then as uh
as ivanka also mentioned next improve
the pieces for example this knight could
start attacking this weak pawn at the
front this bishop uh for example could
at least if it's not doing anything
trade itself off for this white bishop
uh remember this white bishop is
stopping black's access to the defile so
why not trade it off at some point i
think this is just a nice flexible move
and okay he doesn't play this dude he's
known for being a very tricky player and
he's played a move that might be very
good but it also might be very bad oh
he's pushing oh yeah look at that yeah
and he's hoping that white captures this
pawn
i mean white wants to capture this pawn
anyway what is his trick
it looks like he's just lost a pawn for
free because pawn cannot recapture this
is a pin his idea must be to slide his
rook across but what has he missed rook
takes pawn as a check and hitting the
bishop let's go back to the players why
can't white just take this pawn for free
dude
something
clever like uh pushing the pawn up one
square or maybe moving the king out of
the way
i've just lost a pawn for black right
doesn't make any sense
i don't get it i i don't get it from
either player well then i can looking at
the evaluation bar i can see that
white doesn't whites is actually much
much better
i mean fair play to the players they
don't see the evaluation bars so um
neiman now probably just
of course his first instinct is why
can't i take this pawn he's just delving
deep he's trying to calculate duda must
have a trick in mind surely it's not
just hallucination
yes he's had a bad day but that is a
very basic blunder
i'm struggling to explain it it must be
that he wants to slide his rook across
and neiman doesn't call him out on the
bluff
neiman trusting him and i don't it's
mutual blindness i i don't understand
yeah bishop takes pawn it's like the
most
okay i don't want to say obvious move
because obviously both players missed it
but it's a very logical move the rook is
opposite the king
i
my only explanation i think we have to
jump back into the position in a minute
but my only explanation is that they
stopped their calculations one move too
early because white could have won a
pawn for three maybe even two pawns and
uh
yeah we have to show it just because
it's so crazy white stepping back with a
bishop but now black can just move his
king forward he still has all the
long-term advantages we talked about but
bishop takes porn wins the pawn as we
mentioned the only explanation i can
come up with is that rook across looks
like a double attack hitting the white
knight hitting the white bishop so two
pieces under fire but after rook takes
pawn check the king doesn't want to go
to the corner where it will be in the
eye line of the white bishop it needs to
step to the side and maybe here they
both stop thinking okay two pieces are
under attack it's too chaotic and white
can't go for this because indeed if
white captures this bishop for example
then after rook takes check the king
moves the rook can recapture the bishop
and actually black emerges with an extra
piece but what they must have both
missed is that in this position rather
than going okay black attacking these
two pieces rather than going capturing
this bishop white could just move the
knight first the knight is the is the
kind of immediate target so moving out
the way actually threatening checkmate
hitting the black king black only has
one move you have to capture the bishop
but now you capture black's bishop and
after this white has two extra pawns
it's just game over
also white threatening to bring the
knight up with a nasty check and also a
fork hitting the black rook i think it's
this night move that they both missed
and uh maybe we have to ask them about
it earlier this night jump would have
won the game for niemann
[Music]
turn around but missed by the teenager
that's why you should never trust your
opponent even if they're one of the best
players in the world yeah some i mean
they're very human they blunder as well
you can't trust them you have to
calculate
as deeply as possible and uh if we go
back to the game position finally
finally black's king is out of the uh
eye line of this rook it's found safety
and yeah if duda goes ahead and wins
this game if newman doesn't qualify now
for the knockouts he'll look back on
that one move missed opportunity
he did spend a minute or two but it
wasn't long enough
yeah it was a golden opportunity and i
have to say often you can find all these
possibilities by
sticking to the formula of calculating
checks captures and threats and when we
miss them it's because we're not focused
enough or we're just not
actually disciplined when it comes to
this particular thing because it will
solve a lot of things because here the
threat was checkmate
and uh
don't you know
be methodical that's my big advice and
if you say well you know it takes a lot
of energy it's hard work well this is
where practice makes perfect as we say
and just keep on training keep on doing
practicing on this particular thing and
you will get better and in fact you'll
get so good you just do it
subconsciously yeah the other thing is
not making assumptions i've been there
myself when i've played the strongest
players in the world i just think okay
they must have seen everything they must
have calculated everything of course
they never make one move simple blunders
but occasionally it does happen
you just have to work as deeply as
possible and yeah once you've checked
your variations go back retrace your
steps and double check them because you
might see something new and okay now
it's again all in black's favor the
knight as mentioned could come to the
edge of the board and starting to attack
white's doubled pawns
this has forced white tonight pas
white's knight to be passive
black's rook now can start swinging
across behind white isolated pawns on
this side the black rooks could stay
within touching distance of each other
just find a safe square for that rook
and duda has the advantage
it's still white's king as well the more
vulnerable of the two despite the fact
the queens are off
it's it's kind of hard to read the body
language of these players now if they
haven't sort of seen that there was a
huge position
in the in the position a few moves ago
i don't think they've realized duda
never kind of flinched he never kind of
we've seen it before in the tour
suddenly magnus will react when he
realizes
a lot of players react but duda just
stayed calm i think he just
he trusted his calculation but there was
a small hole
uh in his plan and
yeah neiman meanwhile i don't think he
would be looking back he's the type of
player to look forward to be optimistic
to look for his chances but okay dude
i'm making his move for the win now this
pawn stepping forward if it steps
further down the board white's bishop is
actually trapped so there's a huge
threat
uh this pawn if it matches forward
that's game over yeah but i do have to
say one thing that blunders make for
exciting chess i mean
then go watch computers play and i also
really love it when everyone at home
gets involved yeah and sends us their
thoughts their comments and their
selfies and talking about selfies their
big shout out goes to david noffler
singer songwriter also brother of uh dia
straight founder
mark
hi who is watching us from his sofa so
big hello oh i get a starstruck hi
that's actually crazy timing because
when i was in the shower this morning i
was listening to sultan's swing i know
that's your favorite song david my
favorite song
oh wow that is so cool
so david knuffler is a chess fan yeah i
mean how cool i just love it that we
have a whole variety of people watching
the show and uh yeah i also i'm getting
these pimples and so thank you
that is so cool
wow all right well hopefully these two
then puts on the show for david knopfler
following this game and i mean they are
it's a it's a very interesting game do
you think now young christophe duda will
win it it looks likely also he's just
gone one pawn up so there were a few
quick moves there remember there was a
threat to trap white's bishop white's
knight actually moved out the way so
white's bishop does have some escape
squares on this diagonal but in the
process black was allowed to give a
check drive the white king back and now
the first of those double pawns has
dropped so black has a three versus two
advantage now on this left side also
look at all white's remaining pawns
they're all isolated long term the more
trades that happen if the knights
disappear the bishops disappear those
white pawns are easy pickings for
black's pieces
and okay also forced to retreat his
bishop away from the attack from the
black knight it's all gone wrong for
niemann he's even left the board he's
just maybe not uh not so in love with
his position anymore he knows for sure
that duda has this one in his grasp and
duda happy to plant his bishop in the
middle of the board attacking the other
white pawn on that c file one of them is
dropped the under uh the other under
fire
and now if the white knight goes and
captures this black bishop in the center
remember trades only help black likes to
pull up and white's pawns are weak
and also if you compare the remaining
pieces if we see white knight capture
the bishop black's knight keeps the
white bishop in its cage
it's dominant in terms of minor pieces
right now and that's kind of an
important question that everyone at home
and also myself would be asking you know
is it a good time to trade the the
bishop because after all maybe you'll
get bishop against knight maybe you can
have hope but it's so nice to hear okay
no just uh compare the pieces
and uh you definitely don't want to make
those trades and compare the pawn
structure and this will give you a
little bit of an indicator as to what
you should be doing in the future
yeah i think white's last remaining hope
is to go for some kind of a kind of
surprise attack against the black king
maybe using the white knight i think any
trades that happen
your chances of saving this game get
reduced and okay he brings his bishop
out to attack the black rook
at least black's rook now has to dodge
this threat maybe it will slide across
give a check to the white king
but okay this is what's needed in order
to save a game in practical terms you
need to create threats scare your
opponent put the fear of ghosts into
them and eventually they might slip up
they might be careless for a move or
they might overestimate your threats and
go too defensive too passive
uh dude isn't that type of player he'll
look for the maximum but either way
hands keeping peace on the board and
that's the right defensive strategy duda
our polish player in the tournament and
well poland kyra that has been such an
important country um after the war hit
ukraine
they're just receiving a lot of refugees
yeah they received two million
now
and you can also imagine
how many how many children
has crossed the borders into poland
because i think it's very important to
to mention that uh again and again that
this is first and foremost
uh crisis for hunger uh ukrainian
children yeah children crisis yeah
definitely um
we we we we've seen it uh how children
has been
bombed how they've been injured but also
we've seen
how
it has affected
the children we i just saw yesterday
about children becoming catatonic
and not able to talk anymore and things
like this and so imagine in poland
receiving all these children that need
help wow
so definitely uh it's it's it's a
country that has uh yeah we need to
support support poland definitely in
order to tackle this exactly and
receiving so many children
all right a few moves on the board is it
still winning for for ian christoph our
polish player definitely still winning
for him and i think he stumbled across a
great plan for black he actually
advanced another pawn in order to clear
path for the black rook to come across
and slide down and the white king has to
protect two isolated pawns on this left
side but it can't protect them both uh
the black rook the black knight the
black bishop they're all actually
pointing towards this left side of the
board going towards the white king and
there's nothing else for hans to do he
needs to just forget about that left
side it's all going to drop and he's
going at least with the white knight to
try and create some nuisance but yeah
the promise the black bishop on the
board now too strong guarding uh the
black king as well and
those three black pawns aren't going to
win the game they're not that far away
from promotion but also they have
nothing stopping them uh it must be so
nice in an end game to have
three connected pawns that you can just
that's right kaya yeah totally together
pawn structure counts for everything
yeah and as uh in the end game it's all
about promoting pawns
as well as checkmating the king and of
course pawns work best if they're
together and supported by another
sibling and i also have to mention in
this particular position um take a look
at white's pieces you know the rook and
the bishop and the night
there's no coordination there they're
not pointing towards any target and uh
the knight and the rook could be working
together but look who's doing a sterling
job of defense that bishop in the middle
of the board it covers the g7 pawn and
there's just no way through so i mean
white has to be super creative here to
generate any kind of threat
i'm not seeing anything are you i'm not
seeing anything at all also you're stuck
this rook actually creates a pin on the
second rank so this white pawn cannot
advance the white rook would drop behind
it white's king is kind of stuck in
stuck in limbo here it doesn't really
want to continue moving forward it might
be uh might face some checks some nasty
checks also it has to keep an eye on
this black knight but uh most of all
most important of all is now the players
are down to around four minutes each
it's just easy for black to play as you
mentioned these pawns are coming that's
a simple plan
any tom dick or harry could come up with
this plan of pushing pawns for white
what do you do and in rapid chess and
speeches it's all about the simplicity
of plans in the end
white decides okay it's time to push
report and try to open up lines towards
the king but this is easily dealt with
you can even take this pawn if you want
or you can just step forward and block
things up
personally i would probably just take
that pawn off just to get rid of any
potential threat if you step forward
later this pawn might be a bit of a
thorn in the side and you can imagine it
promoting later so why not just get rid
of it
and just capture instead and i don't
think this will help white at all
because after bishop takes you can just
continue your plan and room as yomanga
mentioned this bishop is so strong it
stops any possible checks to the black
king uh because it covers the square
next to it and okay this move is strong
too
just pushing the pawn forward and
white's knight is forced away it's time
to just continue advancing and
still no threats no matter where you
pick up this white knight even if you
have three moves with it there's no
check you can really make without being
captured
so
yeah still very very much in black's
favor thanks to these pawns they're
going to start marching forward very
shortly yeah and uh i was looking i was
desperately trying to see if there was
one way for the white rook to mobilize
itself i mean it needs a little bit of
fairy dust just to kind of
and cheating i'm going to say to get
that rook to anywhere useful i mean it's
just not possible
every time the rook steps up the board
to get somewhere active well there's
just rick takes pawn and all lines and
all squares are covered
and black actually playing a sneaky move
there he could have just advanced his
pawns but uh young christophe duda very
clever just
killing the opponent's fun killing the
opponent's counterplay he's retreated
with his knight so that knight might be
a defender also he's got out of the way
of his own pawn so black seaport can now
come down and give check to the white
king
wow
hans niemann though playing for tricks
he actually gave up his night to lure
the black king
out of its kind of safe refuge there now
the white bishop moves out the way
that's a discover check white's rook
hitting the black king but the black
king can just defend its bishop so it
was a double attack a check and black
bishop was hit in the middle of the
board
that's uh easy it's easy to deal with
and
wow nice nice nice yeah just
why is that so nice
he's threatening checkmate in one move
the black rook is just going to come
behind the white king now deliver the
kiss of death and that's checkmate the
white king's caught in a mating net so
he just abandoned uh the white pawn he's
just forgetting about the white bishop
checkmate is coming in the next few
moves the black rook sliding across and
this is a very common pattern the black
knight supported by a pawn and a black
rook just needs to come next to the king
and there's no way out is that the
perfect team to deliver checkmates and
to win the game yeah knight works super
well with queens especially because they
do the only thing a queen can't but with
rooks in this type of position knights
on outposts are just fantastic would you
find that checkmate secure
would you find that checkmate
no no i didn't see it before it came
good
but actually i thought